so I saw various estimates for socialist
programs like Social Security expansion
free college
Medicare for all will cost upwards of 40
trillion dollars over 10 years for zero
okay they argue with those numbers and
so on but so there's a cost
there's a taxpayer cost what are
given the weight of that cost
uh can you still make the case with
these programs and then can you try to
make the case against them that the cost
is too high so I I will not argue with
you on the numbers because you just
threat random numbers I do think
universal healthcare if Done Right can
be basically cost neutral I think it's
an exception because we spend a
tremendous amount of money on on Health
Care a huge percentage of our GDP so I
think it could be done in a way that's
close to
um class neutral so so can you argue on
the numbers without arguing on the
number so you're saying just your gut
says that there's a lot of depending on
how these programs are done there's a
lot of variants in how much it will
actually cost there's a lot of
bureaucracy in Billing right now in our
Healthcare sector for example that would
be
um eliminated
um there's a lot of costs that are
spiraling upward of Provider costs from
both Doctors Hospitals but also
Pharmaceuticals to drug costs that
insurance companies shoulder because the
their market share is too fragmented to
really negotiate hard
um Medicare can sometimes negotiate
better rates but a Medicare for all
would negotiate even better rates so I
think there's a cost spiral that we can
adjust with more government
um involvement and there's a reason why
we spend a bigger share of our GDP on
health care than other places but but
let me just accept the broad premise
that social programs cost money
um
now
I think that that one for ordinary
people most of them
the trade-off of even hypothetically if
if taxes on
um lower middle class and working less
people in certain cases go up the
trade-off would still be in their
benefit because they're the ones who
currently who would be consuming more of
those goods and also our tax system and
whatnot is Progressive so the the rich
will pay pay more
the majority will consume
um more of them also I think a lot of
these programs are the Bedrock of a
healthy Society
so one reason for example that we have
um so much crime and violence in the US
there's lots of you know cultural and
other
um causes with our level of gun
ownership American history and and so on
but one one really important factor is
just the level of poverty and inequality
in the US compared to other other
countries that combined with guns and
and other factors means we live in more
violent unequal societies if you know a
European would be shocked by the fact
that in even some of our our nicest
areas and our and cities and elsewhere
there's a lot of rural violence too it's
just normal to have gun uh violence it's
normal to have uh drug-related violence
you know the we have what like four or
500 people some years in like Baltimore
like a city of under a million getting
getting killed
um
these are all recipes for society in
which one the public sphere is is drunk
like crazy because you're not gonna go
wander out for an evening stroll in a
park if you live in a dangerous area or
whatever else like the the rot goes very
deep and a welfare state is one way to
to live in a better Society for everyone
um there's been plenty of of studies uh
there's one book called the spirit level
on um on inequality that was quite
popular that just notes that inequality
is really terrible for the psyches
um of the rich too not just for for the
poor so I think uh spending some more
money living in more just Society is is
doable there's different ways to to
address certain costs
um spirals one reason why our welfare
states are getting more and more
expensive is in part just because our
population is is aging but many of the
same people who say we can't afford
um more in our welfare states because
um you know we're already spending so
much on Social Security and all these
other entitlements are the same people
also for one you know closing borders so
immigrants can't come in uh to to help
build the economy and to fill gaps in
the economy and also who aren't for
things that'll make it easier to have
kids you know I'm 33 years old I have a
lot of friends
um who have been putting them off having
kids until they save up x amount of
dollars even though they have someone
they could you know uh raise raise
children with
um because they can't afford the cost of
child care they can't they can't you
know their job probably won't give them
more than four or six weeks of of um
family leave or whatever else like this
is not the case in other other countries
so I think there's all sorts of benefits
from having a bigger uh welfare state
but yes there are costs and there are
going to be certain trade-offs it's not
a magical thing where you could just you
know have everything without trade-offs